there's been a term that's been thrown
around a little bit you know twincest
and it's going to be addressed very soon
on the show what can you tease about
that and what are your thoughts on that
uh well we thought it was funny in the
beginning but now it's actually like
like people like genuinely believe it
it's we never were incestuous like it's
all kind of like a joke that we played
around on set with a probably was taking
a little bit too far my way of
explaining it is just that Cheryl
doesn't feel love for my parents I got
parents have never given her any kind of
a lot of answer awful awful you're awful
humans also I'm I don't care that your
dad has to wear so many wigs like I
don't feel bad for you honey come on
they're so funny and did they address
that a little bit yeah they don't so
much as cool but like Jason had to take
care of her like he took her under her
wing so she caught this like the sense
of like dad brother mom all in one human
yeah he's a lot president
unconditionally loved her so I feel like
she just has this really in there also
twins so like I had this very strange
bond that nobody else understands and
like a lot of the town concepts like
twincest when in reality he's just like
her person like her best friend her mom
her dad her brother the person who takes
care of her like and so losing that just
like it turned her even more to like a
miserable human being
[Music]
you